ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะนะนักเรียนเย้กลับมาเจอครัวตี้
ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอม Rain  Solo ไทยนะครับ
น่าจะเจอกันเป็นประจำนะครับในช่องนี้อ่ะ
ถ้าเจอกับพี่เอ๋เจอกับครัวตี้แล้วก็ต้อง
ทักทายด้วยกัน
ถามวันที่ใช่ไหมฮ่าๆ
แต่ลืมหรอลืมเลยกำลังคิดว่าเจอกันแล้วก็
หายด้วยอะไรอ่อวันที่วันนี้วันอะไรคะอ้า
วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรวันนี้วันพุธครับวัน
นี้วันพุธใช่ครับวันนี้วันพุธนะประการ
กลัวตี้มาแล้วมีวุฒิธรรมวันนี้วันพุธวัน
ที่ทอดวันนี้วันพุธที่ 8 ใส่กับ 18 นะคะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนมิถุนายนเดือน 4
มิถุนายนรักๆครับปีคศอะไรคะมีคศ
2010  22
22  02
2554 คศอะไรคะพี่ขอ 2 ใบ 12
ปีพต
ขอโทษง่วงนอนหรือเปล่าเนี่ยพ.ศ
2565 ครับโอเค
ตลอดกินน้ำเยอะๆดีกว่านะอาจจะหิวข้าวอาจ
จะหิวข้าวเพราะว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยตอนนี้ 6
โมงแล้ว 06:15
นาทีเป็นเวลากินข้าวไงกินแล้ว
วันนี้กินเร็วก็เลยอาจจะ
นอนก็กินข้าวโอเคค่ะ 6 โมง 15 นาทีนคุณ
แม่ครับอาโคโยตี้ค่ะและวันนี้เราเจอกัน
เนี่ยอ่าช่วงนี้เราก็ยังอยู่ในอะไรนะเป็น
อาไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมอ่าท่องเที่ยวประเภทไทย
นะฮ่าๆๆครับปาร์ตี้วันนี้ขวดที่จะพานัก
เรียนกับครูเอ๋ไปเที่ยวที่จังหวัดอะไรคะ
จังหวัดอะไร
อะไรก่อนดีกว่า
เอาเจ
ประเทศไทยมี 6 ภาคใช่ไหมคะครับพอมี 6 ห้า
ครับอย่างเนี้ยจะไปภาคไหนค่ะวันนี้จะไป
ภาคอีสานครับยังคงไปพระเอกอีสัตว์ควยตี้
นี่ชอบไปภาคอีสานมีแต่กูอะตีนะอยู่ใกล้ๆ
แพทย์ใต้นะ
ใส่ใส่ครอบครัวตี้นี่เคยเคยอยู่ที่ภาคอา
สานภาคอีสานหลายจังหวัดในภาครับสายกลัว
ที่เคยไปอยู่เงินก็เลยคิดว่าถ่ายนักเรียน
คาพี่เอกไปเที่ยวภาคอีสานด้วยดีกว่าวัน
นี้ก็ไปภาคอีสานเหมือนกันได้เหมือนเดิม
แต่จังหวัดเปลี่ยนเลยฮะได้ครับเปลี่ยน
เปลี่ยนไปจังหวัดอื่นที่ยังไม่เคยพานัก
เรียนไปบ้างนะครับวันนี้จะพาไปจังหวัด
อะไรคะวันนี้จะพาไปจังหวัดหนองคายนี้
จังหวัดให้อยู่ตรงนี้
ไม่เคยไปเลยยังไม่เคยไปเหรอครับจังหวัด
หนองคายเนี่ยก็อยากไปหมออยากไปใช่ไหมทำไม
ครับถ้าเมียกับโอกาสต้องไปได้อยากไป
หนองคายอยากไปเลยอยากไปอีสานตอนบนขอน้อง
ข้าจะเป็นภาคอีสานข้างบนเราๆฮัลโหลเรียก
ว่า
ข้างอีสานตอนบน
ๆๆๆตอนบนก็คือพระอีสานจะแบ่งเป็นข้างบน
แล้วก็ข้างล่างหนองคายหนักอยู่ข้างบนค่ะ
อีสานแบ่งเป็น 3 ว่ากว่าตี้ข้างบนตรงกลาง
ข้างล่างเล่น 3 เหรอครับเดี๋ยวนะมีแบบนี้
ไหมแบ่งนั้นนี้หรอก็ต้องกลางตรงกลางมีตรง
กลางด้วยนะไม่ใช่เป็นอย่างนี้ค่ะบนกลาง
ล่างขอ
คุยหมายถึงแบ่งแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครับใช่
โอเคนี่ก็งงว่าเอ๊ยไม่เหมือนกันหรอ
ออกไม่เหมือนกันค่ะวัฒนธรรมไม่อ่าใกล้กัน
แต่ไม่เหมือนกันอ่าล่างก็จะติดกัมพูชา
อีสานอีสานบนก็ติดลาวๆว่าบนกับกลางก็ใกล้
ๆกันติดลาวก็จะมีมีมีมีมี
อะไรที่คล้ายๆลาวร้านขายไม้เวียดนามอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะ
ข่าวตอนนี้ไปอีสานบนจังหวัดต้องของคาย
หนองคายก็ติดลาวเหมือนที่พี่เอ๋บอกนะครับ
นี่ปิดลาวหนองคายอยู่ตรงนี้ของข้าอยู่ตรง
นี้อาจลาวอย่างนี้อีกติดกัน
ทุกคนรู้อย่างนึงอ่ะเขานอนขายรู้อะไรครับ
สวยโหที่หนองคายผู้หญิงสวยเลยครับใช่ได้
ยินได้ยินอ๋อ
ครูเอ๋มาจากหนองคายด้วยหรือเปล่าครับไม่ๆ
กูเองไม่เคยไปนั่งหนองคายโอเคเคยไปแต่ได้
ยินหญิงผู้หญิงสวย
โอเคโอเคได้ยินนะครับ
วันที่หนองคายมีอะไรบ้างคะครูอัดตี้มี
อะไรบ้างใช่ไหมที่หนองคายก็จะมีออกคนที่
ไปที่หนองคายเนี่ยก็จะมีที่ที่หนึ่งที่
จัดการไหว้เป็นที่ที่คนเขารบนับถือมากๆ
อ่ะที่นี่ใช่คนไทยเวลาไปเชื่อต้องต้อง
ไหว้พระใช่มั้ยนายเอาแล้วว่าไปต้องมีพระ
ลักษมณ์ให้เราไหว้พระ
เอกกำลังคิด
มีพระองค์หนึ่งที่มีชื่อเสียงมากๆจาก
จังหวัดหนองคายน้ากูเห็นนึกออกมั้ยเดี๋ยว
ถ้ากลัวติ๊บพูดชื่อนะกูเอกก็จะอ๋อ
เออ
ไม่ออก
อ่ะถ้าเป็นพระถ้าเป็นฟ้าที่เป็นคนที่เป็น
พระสงฆ์เนี่ยก็จะชื่อหลวงปู่เทสก์เคย
ได้ยินมั้ยหลวงปู่เทพเทพนะคะเคยได้ยิน
หลวงปู่เทศน์เทศน์รังสีอยู่จังหวัด
หนองคาย
เคยได้อีกละบายแต่ว่าไม่ค่อยได้ฟังท่านนะ
คะอ่ะอามาฟังพระที่อยู่ภาคใต้
ทางอีสานแล้วจะมีพระเก่งๆเยอะมากมายในไป
ครับแต่หลวงพ่อหลวงปู่เทศน์เทศน์รังสีเคย
ได้ยินชื่อครับผมแล้วก็มีพระพุทธรูปอีก
องค์หนึ่งที่มีชื่อเสียงเหมือนกันหน้าคือ
พระพุทธรูปองค์นี้ครับ
คนไทยจะเคยได้ยินชื่อเรียกว่าหลวงพระ
พุทธรูปชื่อหลวงพ่อพระใสเคยได้ยินมั้ยได้
ยินมั้ยพอเห็นไหมกูออกรู้จักอยู่ทั้ง
หนองคายอยู่ต้องบอกว่าคลิปนี้กู M เป็น
นักเรียนด้วยนะคะได้ยินชื่อแต่ไม่เคยไปไง
ไปใครไม่รู้อยู่ที่ไหน
อยู่จังหวัดหนองคาย
[เพลง]
คนที่ไปแล้วก็จะไปสักคนไทยพูดว่าสักการะ
เรานะครับหลักการและก็คือการไหว้นะคะแต่
ไม่ใช่ว่าแบบนี้เป็นกราบกราบด้วยการ
ติดพื้น
การกลับไปกราบหลวงพ่อฟ้าใสล่ะเนาะพระใสขอ
โทษพ่อพระใสๆหลวงพ่อพระใสอ่ะมีชื่อเสียง
ด้านไหนคะอ๋อ
หลวงพ่อพระใสเป็นพระที่เอ่อศักดิ์สิทธิ์
ในด้านของการให้ความสงบร่มเย็นมีคนรอนาย
ไปกราบแล้ว
ตอนนี้เอ๋ไม่สบายใจๆ 3  4  5
ขอให้เอ๋มีสบายใจมากๆมีความสุขมากๆ
สงบใจเย็นนะครับมีความแจ่มใสได้มาใส่ด้วย
นะคะ
แจ่มใส 5
แต่ผมมาแล้ววัดวัดของหลวงพ่อพระใสชื่อวัด
โพธิ์ชัยอยู่ใกล้ๆใกล้ๆกับสะพานอันหนึ่ง
ห้าคู่เอกรู้จักสตางค์ๆสะพานมิตรภาพไทย
ลาว
ทำหน้าที่ชื่อว่าสะพานมิตรภาพไทยลาวเนี่ย
เพราะว่าเป็นงานที่ทำให้คนไทยกับคนลาว
สามารถเดินทางเดินทางไปหากันได้คนไทยก็
เดินท่ามสะพานขับรถท่ามสะพานไปที่ประเทศ
ลาวได้คนลาวก็ขับรถข้ามสะพานมาที่ประเทศ
ไทยๆก็ทำให้เป็นเป็นมิตรต่อกันมีมิตรภาพ
ต่อกันชาตินี้ไทยกับเราจับมือกันทำหรือ
เปล่าอ๋ออันนี้ไม่รู้นะผมจำไม่ได้ว่าใคร
เป็นคนจ่ายเงินให้น่าจะไทยกับเราเพราะว่า
จะคุยทานมิตรภาพไทยลาวๆมีทรายครับๆเป็น
การเชื่อมโยงสองประเทศเข้าด้วยกัน 2
ประเทศไทยแล้วก็ประเทศลาวเชื่อมโยงเข้า
ด้วยกันแต่ว่าถ้าจะค่ะคุณควรที่เคยขับรถ
ข้ามไปไหมคะอ่ะเคยข้ามไปครับขอบคุณข้ามไป
ก็ต้องต้องทำบอเดอร์พาสต้าๆต้องมี
พาสปอร์ตแล้วก็ทำหนังสือข้ามข้ามไปยัง
ประเทศลาว
ได้กี่วันนึกวันทำวันเดียวได้เลยมันใช่
ใช่ครับหมายถึงว่าถ้าครูอาร์ตี้ขับรถจาก
ฝั่งไทยไปฝั่งลาวก็อยู่ที่เราได้ 1 วัน
อ๋ออ๋ออยู่ได้ครับขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเราจะจะ
ทำกี่วันบาง 7 วันหนึ่งไม่เกินหนึ่งได้
ใช่ครับได้ครับก็ได้ตั้งเป็น 1 ถึง 30
วันไหนครับไปเที่ยวได้แล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้มี
เส้นทางรถไฟทางรถไฟจากประเทศจีนรถไฟความ
เร็วสูงความเร็วถูกมากว่าที่เราหน้าที่
ลาวแล้วถ้าอันนี้ถ้าใครต้องการที่จะไป
เที่ยวประเทศลาวนะครับไม่ต้องนั่งรถนานๆ
ถ้าเป็นสมัยก่อนสมัยก่อนถ้าไปเที่ยว
ประเทศลาวไปหลวงพระบางต้องนั่งขับรถนาน
ใช้เวลานานมากไปต้องไปให้ครับใช้เวลา 2
ชั่วโมงสบาย
แล้ว
อยากไปลาวมีเพื่อนอยู่ที่เรา
หน้าตอนนี้เป็นคนเวียดนามที่ลาว
เป็นคนเวียดนามจะอยู่ที่ลาวใช่ไหมใช่เป็น
คนลาวแล้ว
อ๋อเพราะว่าเวียดนามกับลาวติดกันใช่อ่ะมิ
เวียดนามตรงนี้ยาวแล้วก็ต้องนี้ประเทศไทย
ติดกันเป็นทก็เป็นระยะทางแคบไม่ไกลๆ
เพื่อนบอกครู a มากๆกูยังไม่ได้ไปเลย
หาตอนนี้นั่งรถไฟไปได้นะครับนั่งรถไฟใช้
เวลานิดเดียวใช้เวลาไม่นานเดี๋ยวจากไหน
จากไหนอาหมอไปตากเทพถ้าจากกรุงเทพไปก็ใช้
เวลาน่าจะนายประมาณครึ่งวันกรุงเทพไป
หนองคายประมาณ 5 ชั่วโมงรถไฟล่ะมีรถไฟมี
รถไฟด่วนใจครับอ๋อเนี่ยมีเครื่องบินมี
เครื่องบินครับมีเครื่องบินไอเครื่องบิน
ไปที่จังหวัดอุดรธานีอ๋ออ๋อก็ต้องนั่งต่อ
ไปที่หนองคายอีกประมาณ 100 กิโลเมตรเดียว
100 กิโลเมตรใช้
โอเคน่าสนใจนะคะจริงๆแล้วที่หนองคายอากาศ
ดีอันนี้ได้ยินเหมือนกันๆฮ่าๆนักเรียนบอก
ครูเอกหักขาดมีนักเรียนไปซื้อ
ซื้อบ้านก็น่าจะมีแฟนคนไทยแล้วก็เลยซื้อ
บ้านที่หนองคายบอกว่าหนองคายอากาศดีมาก
อ๋อใช่ครับเพราะว่าที่หนองคายเนี่ยอ่อที่
หนองคายเขาจะติดกับแม่น้ำโขงแม่น้ำโขงนะ
ครับค่ะน่าจะติดกับหนองคายไปตลอดเลยครับ
เดี๋ยวผมควรที่อยู่วาดแผนที่ให้ดูอยู่ตรง
นี้แม่น้ำโขงจะตามแนวนี้ครับน่าจะลบนี้
ครับโอเคอ่าแม่น้ำโขงก็ได้ตามแนวของ
จังหวัดหนองคายยาวไปตลอดเลยนายครับมาที่
ลาวแล้วก็มากัมพูชาใช้ขับยาวลงไปเลยเพื่อ
นั้นก็จะติดแม่น้ำตลอดเลยก็จะมีลมเย็นและ
มีน้ำใช่ครับอากาศดี
มีไปจังถ้าอยากไปใช่ไหม
มีแม่น้ำโขงมีก็พักอาศัยไผครับ
เสียงแล้วก็ที่สะพานมิตรภาพไทยลาวใกล้ๆ
กันก็จะมีเอ่อที่เป็นตลาดเรียกว่าตลาด
ท่าเสด็จ
เคยได้ยินชื่อครับอ่าตรงนี้ก็จะขายสินค้า
ขายสินค้าหลายๆอย่างท้ายสิงคโปรพื้นเมือง
ก็มีสินค้าพื้นเมืองของของหนองคายหนองคาย
ใช่ครับแล้วก็มีของที่จัดประเทศเอาเอา
เข้ามาขายในประเทศไทยด้วย
ทั้งคนไทยคนไทยไปเที่ยวหนองคายแล้วไม่
อยากไม่อยากเดินทางข้ามไปประเทศลาวที่ 5
เสด็จตลาดท่าเสด็จนี้ก็จะแต่ของที่เป็น
สินค้าของเราขายด้วย
อะไรนะคุยหาอะไรอยู่มั๊ยครับ
เคยไปซื้ออะไรมาที่ลาวเหรอไม่ได้ซื้อที่
ลาวค่ะอันนี้ได้ยินได้ยินได้ยิน
ได้ยินเอ่อคุยชอบได้ยินค่ะนักเรียน
คือที่ลาวเนี่ยเขาจะมี at อันนี้ไม่ใช่
ของเรานะคะมีเข็มขัดอ๋อใช่เป็นแค่ตัดเงิน
เงินน่ะทำมาจากเงินใช่ไหมครับหน้าหลังจาก
นั้นนะครับเขาแบบมีเข็มขัดเงินที่ลาว
เนี่ยสวยๆครับแต่อันนี้ของกูเองเนี่ยจาก
ชิดจากเชียงใหม่
ไปขายกันคล้ายๆกันเชียงใหม่ก็ติดลาว
เหมือนกันโอ้วแชร์
ขายๆกันค่า
ฮะโอเคแล้วก็อ่าเมื่อกี้ว่าตีบอกว่า
หนองคายนะจ๊ะติดแม่น้ำโขงร้านบริเวณที่
ติดกับแม่น้ำโขงก็จะมีที่ท่องเที่ยวเยอะ
แยะนิร้านอาหารนะตอนกลางคืนแล้วก็ไปเดิน
ที่ตลาดนั่งริมแม่น้ำโขงหน้าอันนี้คือ
ตรงไหนคือร้านอาหารนะคะอ่ะร้านอาหารก็จะ
เนี่ยครับฝั่งนี้จะเป็นร้านอาหารด้วยเป็น
ตลาดด้วยนะครับพรุ่งนี้กันค่ะน้ำติดตลาด
ขายของริมถนนริมริมแม่น้ำโขงตลาดท่าเสด็จ
เหมือนกันแต่ถ้าคนจะนั่งกินอ่ะข้างอย่าง
นั้นน่ะให้หวานควรตีนั่งกินนั่งกินอาหาร
ล่ะอ้าๆใช่ครับอันนี้นั่งกินอาหารริมแม่
น้ำริมแม่น้ำเลยใส่กับตอนนั่งบนเสื่อใช่
มั้ยได้ครับไปนั่งนั่งบนเสื่ออาไม่มี
เก้าอี้ไม่มีเก้าอี้เป็นพื้นบ้านครับพื้น
บ้านนั่งบนเสื่อใจครับอะไรก็กินอาหารกัน
ตัวอย่างนี้หมูกะทะมีก๋วยเตี๋ยวราดหน้าก็
สั่งมากินได้
ข้าวเหนียวส้มตำนี้มีมีแน่นอนเพราะว่าถ้า
ไปที่ภาคอีสานแล้วคนอีสานก็จะกินส้มตำกัน
เยอะค่ะ
สวยดีค่ะอ้าวโอเคแล้วไปที่ที่ที่หนองคาย
แล้วเนี่ยก็พูดถึงหนองคายเนี่ยพูดถึงแม่
น้ำโขงคู่เอกคิดถึงอะไรครับปลาบึกอ่ะเฮ้ย
ก็บวกด้วยมีปลาหมึกด้วยว่า
เอกก็คิดถึงกะอาหารเนาะ
มายเธออย่างนี้คืออย่างนี้อยู่ในแม่น้ำ
โขงเนี่ยเป็นแม่น้ำที่จะมีปลาเราเนี่ย
เป็นปลาน้ำจืดนะคะน้ำจืดขึ้นน้ำในแม่น้ำ
ทะเลเราเรียกน้ำเค็ม M
มาเล่นทะเลมทะเลก็อะไรนะทะเลอันดามันทะเล
ฮาวายอันเนี้ยทะเล
เอาน้ำมันดื่มเอ็มเค็มแต่แม่น้ำเนี่ยน้ำ
เค็มไหมคะอ้าไม่เค็มเป็นน้ำจืดคะใช่ครับ
เอกก็เลยคิดถึงโอ้ปลาที่ตัวใหญ่ที่สุดใน
น้ำจืดเนี่ย
ปลาบึกๆครับมึงจะอยู่ชอบเพราะแม่น้ำโขงไง
เพราะว่าแม่น้ำโขงเนี่ยเป็นแม่น้ำกว้าง
แล้วก็ใหญ่เนี่ยเพื่อนก็จะมีปลาตัวใหญ่ๆ
อยู่ได้นะครับกู Arty  3 คู่เอกก็ระเบิด
อีกปลาหมึกอ่า
ว่าคิดถึงถ้าบอกชื่อตัวนี้กูเอกก็น่าจะ
อ่อตัวนี้นี่เองอ่ะตัวนี้ครับพญานาคใช่
ครับปลาก่อนนะเออ
หน้าตาอะไรคะเนี่ยท่าเสด็จเหมือนกันใช่ๆ
นี้ที่ท่าเสด็จเหมือนกันนะครับหน้าเป็น
บริเวณที่
คนนิยมมาท่องเที่ยวแล้วก็มามาทำอะไรครับ
มาดูค่ะยานากระอามาดูบั้งไฟพญานาคครับ
เพราะว่าพญานาคมี 2  2 สีนะ
สีทองกับสีเขียวนี้ด้วยนะ
เล่นกันตอนนี้ไม่เป็นเพื่อนกัน
หามี 2 ตัวเอาแล้วก็มีบางไฟพญานาคที่บั้ง
ไฟพญานาคยังไงคะว่างไฟเปลี่ยนหน้าก็จะ
เป็นเหมือนกับรุแต่ไม่ใช่ทุกมีลักษณะ
คล้ายๆแตกไม่เหมือนเป็นๆกลมๆใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับเป็นคนลอยขึ้นจากแม่น้ำหน้าลอยขึ้น
จากแม่น้ำตอนกลางคืนนะจะมีพรกลางคืนนะ
ครับถ้าค่ำเดือน 11 ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับเป็น
วันออกอาสาออกพรรษาของทุกปีนะครับขึ้น 15
ค่ำเดือน 11 ๆนี่เอกกำลังจะบอกว่ามีพระ
จันทร์ด้วยอาทำก็คือพระจันทร์ที่กู Arty
ชิเต็มดวง
ขึ้น 5 ค่ำ
พระจันทร์กลมเนี่ยขึ้น 15 ค่ำเดือนก็คือ
เดือนเดือนที่ 11 นายขับไข่อ่ะ
อะไรคือบั้งไฟพญานาคอันนี้ครับวันนี้เป็น
บั้งไฟพญานาคใช่ครับพี่ลอยขึ้นจากน้ำได้
500 ขึ้นมาจากน้ำ
ปกติแล้วถ้าเป็นพุ๊ก็จะมีประกายไฟแบบนี้
ใช่ไหมหน้าแต่บั้งไฟพญานาคจะไม่มีมีเสียง
ไหมคะอ่ามีเสียงครับนัดแต่เสียงจะไม่ดัง
จะไม่ดังเสียงจับเบาๆสิ
ใช่ครับมีเสียงเบาๆแค่ได้เลยครับพี่กู
คุยกับมันเชื่อสวัสดีทำเสียงหรือว่ากดสิ
ไม่ได้โกรธเลยกดเสียงจะเบาเบาๆนุ่มๆจะไม่
เสียงดังปังๆเหมือนกูไม่ใช่ใจกับแล้วก็
ไม่มีแสงแบบนี้นะไม่มีไม่มีก็
บอกว่าสวยมากใช่ครับเพราะว่าสีสีจะไม่จัด
สีจะสีนุ่นนวล
พิมพ์นวลเป็นยังไงเออ
เราดูแล้วเราจะไม่แสบตาจะไม่สวยเก่งคือจะ
ไม่ใช่สีแบบแบบไฟในรูปที่เขาถ่ายมาเนี่ย
ค่ะก็ไม่ใช่สีที่เห็นด้วยตาไงครับไม่ไม่
ใช่คิดตาเราเห็นสีนี้จะสีแบบสีคล้ายๆไฟ
นีออนไหมอาใครๆไฟมีอ่อนที่
เรื่องเรืองเรื่องเรื่องไม่สว่างมากไม่
สว่างจ้าไม่สวรรค์จ้าสีอาทรณ์
ไม่ใส่ใส่คล้ายๆพันจันทร์ใจครับนักเรียน
ดูที่ดวงจันทร์น่ะค่ะปาร์ตี้ชินกับหลักอี
ดวงจันทร์นี่จริงๆแล้วนะ 4 ก็ใกล้ๆกับดวง
จันทร์เนาะครับอะไรๆกัน
แล้วก็ลอยขึ้นจากน้ำๆ
แล้วเวลาเข็นและควรที่เคยไปดูมั้ยกลัว
เต็มไม่ยังไม่เคยไปดูวีดีโอโอกาสแต่ว่า
เออยังไม่เคยไปดูจริงๆจะไปเลยนะอยากไป
ครับอยากไป
แต่ตอนดีน่ะถ้าไปตอนนั้นน่ะคนเยอะมาก
เออเยอะทุกปีฮะค่ะ
ต้องอะไรนะต้องเอาเป็นไปหรือไม่กู Arty
ก็ต้องโทรศัพท์จองจานที่นอนอ่ะอ่อน 3
เดือนนะคะดีๆเพราะคนไปเยอะมากกวนพี่ก็เลย
กลัวที่เคยไปอยู่หนองคายปีหนึ่งเคยไปอยู่
หนองคายปี 1  8 จะไปได้ดูเคยไป
เพราะว่าคนเยอะมากกว่าตีก็คิดว่าคนเยอะ
ไม่ไปดีกว่าไม่ชอบคนเยอะใช่ไหมคะ
เหมือนครูเอ๋ค่ะคนเดียวก็ไม่
อยู่ทีวีบ้างไปไม่ได้ไม่ได้มีตอนกลางวัน
ไม่มีตอนกลางคืนดึกๆใช้น้ำประมาณกี่โมง
คานประมาณที่เขาบอกว่าบั้งไฟในจะมีประมาณ
19:00 นถึงประมาณ 11:00 น
หาบางคนบางคนไปรอดู 19:00 นไม่มี 20:00 น
ไม่มีถามทุ่งไม่มี
บางทีก็มีมี 1 ลูก 2 ลูก 3 ลูกชายก็จะรอ
จนถึง 11:00 นๆครับ 5 ด้วยห้ามท่านหลับ
แล้วบั้งไฟขึ้นมาไม่เห็น
บางใส่กับขึ้นมาก็รอลอยขึ้นมาแล้วก็หายไป
ใช่ไหมๆครับแล้วก็หายไป
ต้องคอยเฝ้าดูเฝ้าดูตลอดเวลาอีชั่วโมง
เขาบอกว่าอันแน่เป็นของพญานาคใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับเขาบอกว่าเกิดจากพญานาคเกิดจากพญานาค
พ่นบางใสข้นอร่อยอ่ะลูกไฟในออกมาหน้าจาก
ในน้ำ
เขาว่าเขาเล่าว่า
จริงไม่จริงอย่างไรเราอยู่ไม่ทราบนะคะแต่
ก็คนไทยจำนวนมากเชื่อว่ามาจากพญานาคก็
ยังยังไม่ยังไม่ได้มีการพิสูจน์จริงๆว่า
คืออะไรยังไม่มีใครเห็นว่าอ้อมีพญานาค
แล้วก็พ่นลูกไฟออกมายังไม่มีใครเห็นแบบ
อื่นๆ
ก็มีขึ้นทุกปีนะคะนักเรียนบางปีนิดหน่อย
บางปีมากๆนะคะ
มีอะไรอีกค่ะโอเคไปดูพญานาคกันแล้วก็อ่า
เดี๋ยวคุณรีบใครไปพาไปดูอีกที่ที่ 1 เป็น
ที่ที่รวบรวม
ศิลปะของหลายๆศาสนารวมกันอยู่ที่มี
ที่ดีครับสวยจังจ้าเป็นศาลาศาลาแก้วกู่
ที่นี่ไม่ใช่วัดนะครับไม่ใช่วัดน่ะเป็น
ศาลานะครับแล้วก็ก็นี้เป็นรูปปั้นไม่ใช่
ไหมคะหานี้เป็นรูปปั้นครับแต่ดูแล้ว
รู้ไหมครับว่าเป็นรูปบ้านของของใครเอออ่า
เดานะคะ 5 ดาวครับเห็นเป็นเป็นผู้ชายแล้ว
ก็เป็นผู้หญิงแบบถูกตอนแรกอ่ะตอนแรกที่กู
อื่นดูตัวเองก็อาจศาสนาฮินดู
ใจครับเป็นสัตว์ยิ่งอู้ใช่ครับถ้าไก่ไก่ๆ
น่ะจะไม่ค่อยเห็นแต่ถ้ากู Arty สูงใกล้ๆ
ครับใกล้ๆปูประเทศผู้หญิงก่อนเห็นผู้หญิง
ปั๊บแล้วมือจับจับโขนกลับมาว่านี่จับ
คนนี้กูเองรู้จักมาก็เลยรู้ใช่ไหมครับ
เป็นภาพประจำที่ห้าๆเป็นท่าประจำของคนนี้
โอเคของพระพระแม่อุมาขอพระแม่อุมาในศาสนา
เมื่อคุณดูนะคะพอแม่อุมาใกล้ๆกูเอกก็เลย
เดาว่าน่าจะเป็นสามีอ๋ออ๋อนี่ใช่ไหมครับ
ให้เป็นสามีแต่ดูจากคอแล้วเนี่ยน่าจะเป็น
พระศิวะขอ
เป็นพระศิวะที่
พระศิวะที่คอจะมีงูได้ใช่ไหมๆมีไหมมีไหม
กับผัวกะโหลกหรือ
ถ้ามีอุมาก็น่าจะมีพระแม่อุมาก็น่าจะมี
พระศิวะอ๋ออ๋อเพราะว่าคู่กันใช่ไหมครับ
อ่ะคู่กันโอเคใช่ 5 ที่นี่นะครับ
ใช่ครับใช่ครับ
มีแขนเยอะๆแขน 5 ใส่ครับมีแขนเยอะๆที่นี่
ออกก็จะมีรูปปั้นแบบนี้นะครับประมาณ
e260 ใช่ก็จะมีของเบียร์นะฮ่าของศาสนา
ฮินดูศาสนาคริสต์ศาสนาพุทธหรือว่ามีเป็น
พวกรำมาเรียนด้วยรวมกันประมาณ 200 รูปภาพ
จึงร่วมกันอาริสพุธ r&i ครับแล้วก็อะไรนะ
เป็นรามายณะเดี๋ยวเรามากินน้ำอาเจียนได้
ครับหน้าที่นี่ก็เป็นเป็นแบบคนไทยคนไทยทำ
ใช่ไหมคะให้ครับเป็นของคนไทยคนไทยคำ
ขอเคยเห็นพระ
พระพุทธรูปข้างหลังกว่าตี้
ในครับนี่หรอครับฤทธิ์ธิปตะชัยๆๆๆนี้ที่
อยู่ด้านหลังตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
อามีศาสนาพุทธนะคะ
พระพุทธรูปแล้วก็ติด 1 องค์อะไรไม่ทราบนะ
คะอ่ะสีสเปรย์รู้จักแค่ 2 นะคะต้องไปดู
ต้องไปดูต้องไปดูมีเยอะมากเดินดู
Learn เลยครับครัวดิไปครั้งหนึ่ง
ไปแล้วสวยมากเลยค่ะสวยครับแต่ก็ร้อน
เหมือนเอาไข่หมด
อยู่ใกล้ๆกันถ้าไปที่อำเภอเมืองหนองคาย
เที่ยวได้หลายที่รอบๆมีสถานที่ท่องเที่ยว
เยอะเลยแต่ครับเธอ
ก็อ้าที่นี่เข้าฟรีหรือเสียเงินค่ะอ่าตอน
นั้นตอนนั้นควรตีเข้าไปเสียเงิน 20 บาท
ตอนนี้ไม่รู้อาจจะขึ้นแล้วไม่แน่ใจอาจจะ
50 บาทไม่แน่ใจอ่าอะไรครับขอโทษนะคะคน
ไทย 20 บาทคนต่างชาติก็
ก็หาจะบวกไปอีกนิดนึงให้ 100 บาทไม่แน่ใจ
ใจนะคะไม่แน่ใจโอเค
แต่ก่อนจะหมดเวลาเดี๋ยวไปเที่ยวกันแล้ว
ครูเอกต้องเริ่มหิวแล้วใช่มั้ยเต็มไม่ได้
ค่ะคลิป
clip ของคนไทยไว้พระใช่
ปี้แล้วก็ต้องกินได้ครับเข้าไปที่ไหนเข้า
ไปที่หนองคายอาหารที่คนจะนึกถึงต้องเป็น
อันนี้ครับ
อะไรครับแอมแอ๋มเนื้อเรื่องใส่แล้วแหนม
เนื้อเนื้องานแนะนำเนื่อง
หนองคายมีคนเวียดนามอพยพมา
อยู่ที่หนองคายมันเยอะนะคะน่าอร่อย
อร่อยครับที่ครัวที่ชอบแหนมเนืองเพราะว่า
แหนมเนืองเนี่ยมีผักเยอะ
หน้าเวลากินแหนมเนืองเราจะกินกับผักเยอะ
แยะมากมายนี่ผักแปลกๆและขณะน่ากลัวแต่ไม่
รู้จักด้วยแต่ก็กินอร่อยดีเอาที่จะก่อน
เนี่ยมีอะไรตื่นให้นี่ครับอย่านะอย่ากวน
ตีขยับไปกล้วยอย่าไปภาพนี้
อ้านี่ครับเห็นชัดๆมีกล้วยมีเป็นแต่เป็น
กล้วยกล้วยดิบนะไม่ใช่ที่บ้านกูเองมีอยู่
ค่ะ
หลักก็มีมะม่วงมุงอร่อยๆเดี๋ยว
ถ้ามีแต่งกว่าโต๊ะกรอบกรอบใจครับถ้าที่
สำคัญคนไทยคนไทยต้องมีสิ่งนี้ครับของไม่
ดีเลยพริกได้ครับมีพริกไงคนไทยชอบกินเผ็ด
แล้วก็มีกระเทียมไหมคะมีกระเทียมด้วยใช่
ครับ
นี่หลายๆอย่างก็มีผักเยอะๆนี่ไงครับหัวตี
ชอบผักนี้ที่สุดเลยผักติ้วหรอค่ะดูใบ
มะกรูดอุปกรณ์หมอเขาเรียกว่าอะไรครับที่
มันเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยวๆครับมีรสเปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยวๆหน่อยมันจะมีสองอย่างงั้นกู Arty
ไปทำงานก็ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่จะมีสองอย่างที่
เหมือนกันดูแล้วเหมือนกันก็คือเหล็กใบ
ติ้วขอ
ทำไปติว 2 ใบมะกอก
ที่ไม่เคยรู้หรอกชื่ออะไรกินแล้วเปรี้ยว
โอเคอร่อยๆชอบ
ท่าชะมวงชะมวงก็เปรี้ยวแต่จะบวมจะจำ
ชั่วโมงจะอยู่ที่ระยองจันทบุรีอาหารสมง
อยู่ภาคใต้ใช่ไหมครับมันออกออกและภาคใต้
ก็มีคนไปซอยตี๋เคยกินชั่วโมงนี้ภาคใต้
อ่ะโอเคได้แต่ทางอีสานไม่มีหนออาจจะเป็น
ผักติ้วใช่ไหมนัทไม่รู้ว่าติวหรือมันออก
มี 2 ตัวค่ะโอเคดูแล้วมันจะคล้ายๆกันนะคะ
แต่งกลิ่นกลิ่นน่ะจะไม่เหมือนกันแต่ว่า
ไทยใช่ๆซะงั้นก็จะมีรสชาติเปรี้ยวเปรี้ยว
ฝาดฝาดหรือไม่กลิ่นแปลกๆของหอมๆๆแผนที่เอ
ชอบคืออันฟันเนี่ยอันไหนครับอันนี้ให้อัด
อันนี้อันนี้หรอไม่ใช่ไม่ลงอีกนั่นแหละ
นั่นแหละของดีเรียกว่าอะไรครับผักพักแถว
หอพักแพรวเฮ็ดแล้วถึงเวลากินก็จะเหมือนยา
นิดหน่อยใช่ไหมใช่ไหมจืดจะมีกลินมีกลิ่น
นะคะมีกลิ่นนะโอเคกินกับอ่าแหนมเนื้อ
เรื่องใช่ไหม
ต้องกินที่หนองคายกู S5 หนองคายแหนมว่า
อร่อยสิฮ่าๆๆ
ทันทีด้วยอร่อยต้นตำรับของอาหารเวียดนาม
ใช้ใส่อะไรไทยใช่ครับว่าในไทยนะคะพี่
หนองคายหาที่หนองคายเอง
ถ้าพูดแล้วสามารถซื้อมาได้นะพนักงานขับรถ
ไปเขามีจัดเป็นชุดนะค่ะนายไปกรุงเทพฯซื้อ
กลับไปเชียงใหม่ได้ได้ครับ
หิวจริงๆแค่วันนี้ไปหนองคายหิวแล้วนะครับ
อ่าไม่หิวสิก็ผู้เพิ่งกินข้าวเมื่อกี้ถอด
ออกมาว่าหิวได้
กลับบ้านหิวได้
โอเคค่ะงั้นเดี๋ยวกลับมาเจอกันใหม่ครับ
ทุกหน้าเราจะพากันไปเที่ยวไหนเดี๋ยวรอติด
ตามนะครับควรกูพี่เอ๋ได้ในช่องคอมเพลส
เซอร์เวอร์ Server ไทยเหมือนเดิมนะครับ
ทุกวันนี้ปาร์ตี้กับกูเหลาไว้ก่อนแล้ว
ครับอ่ะแล้วพี่เอ๋สวัสดิการ
ภายใน